qué voy a plantear si existe el botón de
compra cerebral es una interesante
pregunta es decir si sabemos qué sucede
en el cerebro cuando tomamos una
decisión de compra o no ahí está la
pregunta existe el botón de compra
cerebral si os hago una pregunta solo
voy a hacer una si levantas la mano
quién de vosotros quiere influir en la
toma de decisiones de las personas
branding marketing comunicación
publicidad en el fondo todos queremos
influir en la decisión de compra de la
gente para que compren nuestros
servicios o nuestros productos en la
siguiente pregunta que plantearía si son
válidas las las técnicas actuales
todos sabemos que en un focus groups
puede haber un líder que haga que exista
un sesgo en ese resultado de un
ejercicio las encuestas fallan como una
escopeta de ferias tienen un margen de
error
elevadísimo y aparece el neuromarketing
disciplina que hace unos años llegó
prometiendo precisamente eso
vamos a trabajar más en una respuesta
cerebral y menos en una respuesta
declarativa nosotros fuimos a muchas
charlas donde fuimos a ver a los gurús
de neuromarketing fuimos con científicos
camuflados
y detectamos que salían de las charlas
diciendo si lo que dice es verdad y lo
puede demostrar científicamente a este
tipo le tenía que dar el nobel
básicamente la conclusión a la que
llegamos es que había mucho marketing
pero poco neuro y acuñamos el término
main de collings de codificación de la
mente y la siguiente pregunta es
precisamente cómo evitar el sesgo de la
respuesta declarativa en todos los
estudios de mercado tradicionales
preguntamos y escuchamos sus respuestas
no queremos esas respuestas conscientes
y no queremos las respuestas pre
conscientes
y acudimos a la ciencia la ciencia con
mayúsculas al centro de tecnología
biomédica que está en el campus de
montegancedo en pozuelo
qué se dedica a investigación sobre
enfermedades neurodegenerativas y lidera
un proyecto a nivel internacional de
investigación sobre alzheimer y más en
concreto con el laboratorio de
neurociencia cognitiva y computacional
dirigido por fernando maeztu que son
unos 45 científicos entre biólogos
matemáticos físicos psicólogos y es
precisamente esta especie de torre de
babel del conocimiento lo que hace que
de ese centro salgan muchísimas
investigaciones y publicaciones
científicas tuvimos la suerte de más que
llegamos en un momento en que tanto en
españa como en europa como en eeuu se le
pedía a la ciencia precisamente eso
transferir conocimientos señores
científicos está muy bien si sacamos
cosas aplicables al mundo real y eso nos
ayudó pero lo primero que nos dijo
fernando va estuve el director del
laboratorio es olvidarnos del botón de
compra cerebral eso es una chorrada eso
es imposible
hoy voy a decir una cosa la intuición no
existe fue de las cosas que más me ha
aportado a mí personalmente se llama
memoria implícita qué significa esto
siento aquí las mujeres lo de la
intuición femenina y esas cosas
la intuición no existe se llama memoria
implícita y significa lo siguiente hay
muchas cosas que sabemos y que somos
conscientes de que lo sabemos pero hay
muchísimas más otras cosas que sabemos
pero no somos conscientes de lo que
sabemos entonces la memoria implícita
están cosas tan sencillas como tarta los
cordones de montar en bici no lo piensas
lo haces directamente y pensamos que ahí
está realmente la respuesta que queremos
en ese espacio de la memoria implícita
donde una respuesta pre consciente que
no he pensado todavía la pregunta de
cómo acceder a esa memoria implícita
bien como accedo ahí sí preguntando no
puedo acceder como accedo pues la
respuesta nos la dio el laboratorio esta
especie de secador gigante que está en
una máquina se llama
magnetoencefalografía está en un cuarto
de tres por tres para que os hagáis una
idea sólo hay dos en españa uno está
aquí en este centro y otra en el país
vasco cuesta dos millones de euros la
maquinita
y otro millón de euros la habitación
donde está seguro que conocéis más de
uno ese casco de electroencefalografía
danesa otra tecnología que sí que se
utiliza más más a menudo lo bueno que
tiene el magneto es que tanto la
resolución espacial como temporal desde
el milisegundo y milímetro o sea es la
máquina más precisa que existe para
tomar mediciones cerebrales y lo bueno
además es que a diferencia de otras como
ésta que abrirte la cabeza y tocar
directamente pues existe no invasiva
chicos esto es ciencia hay que
investigar aquí están años investigando
y os propongo lo siguiente nos dijeron
del laboratorio si os parece si
investigamos qué pasa cuando algo te
gusta o no te gusta
y después qué pasa cuando un precio es
adecuado o no entiendo que si algo te
gusta y el precio es adecuado paras más
cerca del botón de compra famoso que
estamos buscando
hicimos dos experimentos el primero
tres categorías diferentes moda plantas
coches les preguntábamos a las personas
si le gustaba o no le gustaba
conductualmente dentro de la magneto
ellos respondían me gusta no me gusta
pero nosotros estábamos leyendo la
respuesta cerebral nuestras neuronas
emiten corrientes eléctricas que generan
campos magnéticos y eso es lo que la
magneto precisamente mide
las conclusiones es que descubrimos una
cosa científica impresionante que
estudió bellas artes existe universal de
me gusta algo que pasa en el cerebro
cuando se conectan siete ciertos
patrones de conexión entre partes
diferentes del cerebro cuando algo te
gusta y no te gusta por lo tanto
podríamos predecir cuando alguien le
está gustando algo o no si ni siquiera
preguntárselo
después de este ejercicio les pusimos un
precio a esos estímulos gráficos que
habían gustado un precio normal otro
precio alto otro precio bajo de nuevo
respondían conductualmente pero nosotros
estábamos midiendo la actividad cerebral
que conclusiones pues que hay perfiles
de actividad cerebral diferentes cuando
un precio es adecuado o no estos son
imágenes reales que salen del centro de
tecnología biomédica no bien no voy a
meterme mucho en la ciencia pero pasó
algo muy interesante es decir que cuando
un precio y no te encaja es inmediato
los primeros milisegundos noté que no me
gusta luego ya tardamos un poquito más
hasta 300 milisegundos en decidir el
cerebro es el que lo decide si algo no
nos gusta o si el precio no nos encaja
perdonar al revés él no es lo primero el
si es lo segundo
y además se genera una disonancia a los
400 milisegundos
ahora os explicaré
esta onda n 400 bueno después de estos
dos experimentos en el que nos apoyamos
es a un paradigma de los años 80 de kut
así hyler que se llama la disonancia
semántica qué significa esto
que si yo os digo por ejemplo se compra
el pan en la luna al decir en la luna
nuestro cerebro aparece esa onda n-400
que genera una disonancia pues no tienen
un sentido el pan no se cumple en la
luna no sé qué hago no tengo una
panadería que es que se llama en la luna
cerca de casa se nos ocurrió aplicarlo a
precios me parece adecuado no me parece
adecuado y midiendo esa intensidad de la
onda en 400 podríamos graduar el precio
adecuado pero también atributos
semánticos los que hemos hablado de
marca que transmite una marca le pongo
un logotipo
con una creatividad y lo asocio con un
atributo semántico
calidad salud caro y vas midiendo
precisamente esa intensidad de la onda n
400 para saber exactamente lo que pasa
en el cerebro sabemos cuando algo te
gusta y no te gusta y además sabemos el
precio adecuado al que estás dispuesto a
comprarlo
esto es una información muy valiosa de
acuerdo pero tiene aplicación real pues
la tiene voy a contar un caso un cliente
de tecnología lanzaba un smartphone
campaña global spot único concepto
disruptivo quería conquistar un
territorio nuevo diversión y juego
la pregunta era si el consumidor acepta
o no ese nuevo territorio y que
transmite la marca y el nuevo producto
pues lo que hicimos fue un estudio
conductual clásico es decir juntamos
personas de diferente segmentación y les
preguntamos jugaron con el aparatito lo
vieron les preguntamos y conductualmente
salieron estas cosas atributos positivos
y algunos negativos que pasó cuando
hicimos el análisis cerebral en la
magneto pues que desaparecieron los
atributos negativos esto nos da que
pensar a ti tú vas a un ejercicio de una
marca te preguntan qué te transmite algo
y yo creo que te sientes obligado a
decir cosas buenas y cosas malas
probablemente aunque realmente no las
estés pensando
básicamente los atributos agregados
negativos desaparecieron en el análisis
cerebral cogimos estos atributos y les
preguntamos además por un competidor
este terminal de smartphone transmitía
estas cosas a la gente casualmente
el cliente que el atestado estaba todo
bastante bien el competidor pues estaba
bastante mal excepto aquí en calidad más
o menos similar bueno era curioso que
pasa en análisis cerebral que pasaba en
esa respuesta pre consciente pues
realmente que los atributos positivos
son inherentes a la categoría de los
smartphones todos sabemos que son
modernos da igual el que te pongan no es
decir que no es moderno que no es
novedoso que no es polivalente y
curiosamente diversión y juego que en el
territorio que querían conquistar ni
siquiera aparecía estos dos atributos lo
metimos es sugerido es decir cuando es
un ejercicio declarativo te diste en
unos atributos pero si no sale lo que tú
quieres testar pues los metes no
salieron ni en el declarativo
ni en el cerebral y además hicimos el
ejercicio de prising
y les dijimos que su producto estaba des
posicionado en precio hasta un 25 por
ciento por encima noticias malísimas
para el cliente que cogió nuestro
informe lo que tiene un cajón y dijo
hasta luego
aquí y aquí os quedáis muy bien chavales
nos llamó porque era conocido nos llamó
a los seis meses para decirnos que
ciertas decisiones de directores de
marketing en europa habían avalado
nuestras nuestras tesis valientes nos
quedamos bastante satisfechos en ese
sentido y aplicaciones a negocio tiene
esto pues se nos ocurren muchas seguro
que vosotros otras pero conocer la
imagen de la compañía productos marcas
sus marcas definir mapas de atributos
semánticos y compararlos con el
competidor para ver realmente dónde
estás oye tú transmites esto tu
competidores tu territorio lo estás
ganando por aquí
rediseñado el logotipo las decisiones
normalmente las empresas tras tenido que
tirar de la lengua a muchos directores
respecto a temas de marca de cierre
primera la sensación de que al final
de 3 o 4 logotipos se lo pregunto a mi
mujer a mis hijos y les gusta más este
puesto
creemos que tanto rediseñado el logotipo
como en un clip como en cualquier
creatividad publicitaria se pueden
testar dos cosas si gusta o no gusta y
si transmite los atributos semánticos
que tú quieres que transmita tomar caos
que son los que tú quieres que
transmitan
criterios de compra y no compra es súper
interesante saber por qué te compran
pero muchísimo más interesante de saber
por qué no te compran y compararte con
un competidor es noticia que no te están
comprando por estas diez cosas bien
resulta que son estas cuatro las que
hacen realmente impacto en el cerebro
las demás a las que dicen pero en el
fondo son estas cuatro además sobre en
otro orden que tú esperabas y además a
tu competidor tiene este atributo
concreto en el que te gana y tú puedes
definir tu estrategia de marca
definición del target óptimo esto ya
sería un ejercicio con muchos más
sujetos pero también podríamos llegar a
decir tú lanzas un coche no sabes muy
bien a quién
a qué segmentación te diriges pues a lo
mejor al final salen los jóvenes de 12 a
14 años personas de 12 a 24 años y las
mujeres de 40 a 45 ese es el target
concreto de tu producto
estrategias de precios
análisis del customer journey este
famoso indicador de recomendación que
todas las empresas tienen obligado tener
en cuenta en sus estrategias de
compañías
bueno pues podemos medir esos momentos
de la verdad esos momentos de dolor
concretos preguntándole a los sujetos y
a la vez midiendo su respuesta cerebral
de tal forma que tendríamos snps
cerebral en el que ya estamos trabajando
los valores asociadas a un personaje
cuando contratamos a un personaje como
abanderado de nuestra marca porque
conozco es que como cromáticas para
entonces al final pues lo utilizo para
el anuncio bueno pues busquemos esos
personajes miramos esos valores que
transmiten y que se adecuen a tu marca
haciendo esto a una decisión vale
sueltos y tienes tres o cuatro pues
podrás decidir en este campo nadie se ha
metido todavía esperamos que alguien lo
haga no sé si alguien de aquí es de
recursos humanos porque hay un pelín de
problema ético es decir no es que
estemos leyendo la mente pero si a ti te
preguntan por tu nuevo jefe
soy tu nuevo jefe va a ser este que te
ha parecido
el sueldo a la oficina todo fenomenal
que vas a decir si tú tienes que decidir
entre tres directores generales para tu
empresa donde te la juegas por lo menos
entender que transmite cada uno a qué
juega cada uno es decir en ese momento
igual que hace diez años nadie pensaría
que si gana cien entrevistas por
videoconferencia hoy en día se hace
todos los días el algo ético cómo voy a
hacer una entrevista online por la mente
de conocerle pues esto al final se
aplicará en employer branding funciona
muy bien que transmite tu marca yo
quiero captar este tipo de empleados
bueno pues si tú transmites lo que ellos
quieren que transmitas pues te podrás
acercar más a ellos hay se les anima y
esto aquí tenía una foto de los cinco
magníficos de las elecciones que
acabamos de tener por cuarta vez en
cuatro años
me encantaría hacer ese ejercicio
meterles en la máquina a los cinco y
sobre todo empezar a preguntar qué es la
derecha que es la izquierda es la
extrema derecha que es la extrema
izquierda qué atributos semánticos de
este lado nosotros nos llevaríamos
muchas sorpresas probablemente haría
cosas de la extrema izquierda extrema
derecha que funcionan exactamente
y bueno ahí podríamos dar muchísimas
pistas de eso ojalá lleguemos a hacerlo
y para acabar solo deciros que hemos
llevamos 34 años trabajando en este en
este proyecto y que de momento sólo
hemos conseguido medir estímulos
gráficos y estímulos atributos dentro de
esa magneto pero estamos trabajando ya
en la medición de audiovisuales miren
ese anuncio de hasta seis segundos
darnos cuenta que se generan millones de
datos en cada en cada cerebro
se necesita una tecnología excesivamente
potente sobre todo de ordenadores para
llegar pero ya estamos en los 6 segundos
y por último dejaros con la sensación de
que estábamos a bastante y que ya está
demostrado que por ejemplo en un grupo
de música
con cascos de eje puestos hay una
sincronización inter cerebral
un poco más que la neurociencia se está
aplicando a negocio ha venido para
quedarse le falta mucho esto es ciencia
pura con mayúsculas y el neuromarketing
está evolucionando también de la forma
adecuada dirección yo no quiero echar a
tierra el neuromarketing porque tiene
sus cosas buenas y tiene que ir
aprendiendo de sus errores nada más
brotes